this is a chart of covid19 cases in the
uk
in april the uk's rate of new cases
climbed so high that it was second only
to the u.s
around that time researchers at oxford
university who were developing a covid19
vaccine
had started planning to do a large-scale
test of the vaccine in the uk
but by july new covenanting cases in the
country had fallen
it was good news but it also meant the
uk was no longer
a good place to test a vaccine and
that's because of a crucial part of the
process of testing any new vaccine
what's called the phase 3 human trials
before we can end the coronavirus
pandemic
a vaccine developer will have to give
tens of thousands of participants either
the vaccine
or a placebo and then we wait
for months or possibly years to see how
many of each group eventually gets
coveted 19
while the participants go about their
lives which right now
probably means they're living under
cover 19 restrictions like wearing masks
and staying at home
but until enough of those participants
get sick there won't be enough data on
whether the vaccine is working
and in the meantime thousands of people
are dying of copenhagen
every day that's why some people are
starting to advocate a different
more controversial model instead of
waiting for the coronavirus to
eventually
infect some of these people what if we
gave a group of willing volunteers the
virus
on purpose i'm a young guy 23 years old
i'm
relatively healthy i have no
pre-existing health conditions i have no
children
no dependents it's really important that
we do everything
we can to speed up research and
development
[Music]
it's 2016 and this man is about to drink
a test tube
of the bacteria that causes typhoid he's
one of about a hundred participants who
deliberately infected themselves with it
to test a new vaccine in the uk
in march 2016
[Music]
i downed a shot of typhoid dinah was
another participant she was a phd
student who needed the money but she
also liked the idea of it
it was like you know i'm helping to make
this disease less deadly
this kind of study is called a human
challenge trial
and in the case of the typhoid vaccine
researchers told the new york times that
doing the challenge
trial saved them three or four years to
put that in context
it helps to look at the bigger picture
of how a vaccine normally gets developed
the first step in the process is to test
a vaccine in a lab on either human cells
or on animals
just to see if it causes any harm this
is called the pre-clinical phase
if it passes that test it enters human
trials
this is the longest and most important
part
if it passes human trials the vaccine
gets licensed by regulators
and can be manufactured and distributed
to the public
human trials typically have three phases
each one testing
a larger and larger group of people
phase one involves a very small group of
people maybe 50.
it mainly tests if the vaccine is safe
phase 2 usually involves a few hundred
participants
this is where we start learning if the
vaccine actually works
and then there's the final test the
phase three trial
it's expensive it takes time it requires
tens of thousands of volunteers
and it involves as broad a cross-section
of participants as possible
the entire process of developing a
vaccine
usually takes around 10 years but many
covid19 vaccine developers are racing to
compress
this entire process into about a year
and a half
one way they are doing this is to
overlap the different phases conducting
several different trials at once
or to ramp up the manufacturing of a
vaccine while it's still being tested so
that if it works it can be distributed
right away
as of the making of this video there
were 166 covid18 vaccines in various
stages of development
24 vaccine candidates are already in the
human trial phase
and five of them are already in phase
three
for these leading candidates a human
challenge trial could save weeks or
months by augmenting a phase three trial
that isn't getting data fast enough
and for any of these candidates in
pre-clinical phases
a child study followed by a larger skill
safety study for the vaccine
could replace a phase 3 trial altogether
a challenge trial that successfully
shrinks down this timeline could save
thousands of lives and so far a
grassroots movement has recruited more
than thirty thousand volunteers from
over a hundred countries
who said they would participate in a
challenge trial for cover 19
if it happens my moral values say that i
kind of have an
obligation to do what i can to help i
see it as very similar to
other acts of public service like trying
to fight climate change and
disastrous events that are forthcoming
that are the consequences of the lack of
care
it's affecting literally pretty much
every person globally
i feel like i need to do something to
help
here's the problem human challenge
studies have been used before for
cholera
typhoid malaria influenza and the common
cold
but there's a big important difference
that sets covenanting apart
for each of those conditions we do have
effective treatment so that we know
to my knowledge no one has actually ever
died in those studies
peter smith is one of the world's
leading epidemiologists
and he was one of the first to advocate
for the possibility of human challenge
trials in march of this year
he says because there is no covenanting
treatment it limits who could
participate in a challenged study
challenge trial would necessarily be
done in people who were at very low risk
of serious disease
in other words unlike in a typical phase
3 trial where you'd recruit the widest
range of people
possible the covenanting challenge trial
would produce data on a much narrower
group of young healthy people
and we don't know if a vaccine that
works for that group would work for
everyone
but the immediate goal is not to get a
single covid19 vaccine that offers
perfect protection
in the u.s to be deemed sufficiently
effective a vaccine just has to work
50 percent better than not being
vaccinated
an imperfect vaccine could still slow
the spread of the virus
the bigger issue with a covid19
challenge study is that there's no way
to guarantee that it's actually safe for
participants
on one hand the risk of hospitalization
for young people is relatively
low and a study of the outbreak in new
york city
suggests the risk of death for young
people is as low as .01 percent
and advocates for covenant 19 challenge
trials say that's a level of risk
we already accept in similar situations
they point out it's even lower than the
risk of fatality from donating a kidney
but any risk of harm or death at all
would still set it way apart from any
other challenge study
in the long-term risks of covenanting
for those who recover
are still almost entirely unknown we
emailed nearly all of the institutions
who were reachable who are currently
developing a vaccine
to see whether they would consider human
challenge trials
and none would go on the record saying
they're considering it
but we know that at least one is
seriously considering it
developers of the oxford university
vaccine said that they hope to do
challenge trials by the end of the year
in 2016 the world health organization's
stance on human challenge studies was
that
it would not be ethical or safe to use
them for a disease that is verulent
and has no existing therapies to treat
it but in may of this
year they released new guidelines saying
that they could theoretically be
considered if there was confidence
that the potential benefits of sars cov2
challenge studies outweigh the risks
if challenge studies do reduce the time
it takes to get a vaccine
those benefits are clear
if the current leading candidates have
quick successful phase 3 trials
we may never need to do a challenge
trial for covert 19
at all but if we do it'll only be
possible
because there are people out there
willing to take on
this risk it's worth it to me
to save the lives of a countless number
of people
i'm happy to take that small risk to
myself
and make things better for a lot of
people feeling like i was doing nothing
and and just feeling miserable and
demoralized to being like
okay like i have something i can do here
well i'm a lot less at risk than my
parents and grandparents are and my
moral imperative tells me i have to do
[Music]
it
you